boy price is a man that most of you have
probably never heard about even though
he may have been responsible for 22
somewhat mediocre minutes of your life
on April 19 2013 he may have also been
responsible for 22 very entertaining
minutes but not very many of you and all
of that goes back to a decision that Roy
had to make about three years ago so you
see Roy Price is a senior executive with
Amazon Studios that's the TV production
company of Amazon he's 47 years old slim
spiky hair describes himself on Twitter
as movies TV technology tacos and Roy
Price has a very responsible job because
it's his responsibility to pick the
shows the original content that Amazon
is going to make and of course that's a
highly competitive space I mean there
are so many TV shows already out there
that Roy can't just choose any show he
has to find shows that are really really
great so in other words he has to find
shows that are on the very right end of
this curve here so this curve here is
the rating distribution of about 2500 TV
shows on the website IMDB and the rating
goes from 1 to 10 and the high tier
shows you how many shows get that rating
so if your show gets a rating of 9
points or higher that's a winner then
you have a top 2% show that's that shows
like breaking bad Game of Thrones The
Wire so all of these shows that are
addictive where after you watch the
season your brain is basically it's like
where can I get more of these episodes
right so that kind of trip on the left
side just for clarity here on that end
you have a show called toddlers and
tiaras
which should tell you enough about
what's going on on that end of the curve
now Roy price is not worried about you
know getting on the left end of the
curve because I think you would have to
have some serious brain power into
undercutting toddlers and tiaras so what
he's worried about is there's this
middle bulb here the the Bulge of
average TV and other shows that aren't
really good really bad they don't really
get you excited so he needs to make sure
that he's really on the right end of
this and so a pressure is on and and of
course it's also the first time that
Amazon is even doing something like this
so Roy price does not want to take any
chances he wants to engineer success he
needs a guaranteed success and so what
he does is he holds a competition so he
takes a bunch of ideas for TV shows and
from those ideas through an evaluation
they select eight candidates for TV
shows and then he just makes the first
episode of each one of these shows and
puts them online for free for everyone
to watch and so when Amazon is giving
out free stuff you're going to take it
right so millions of viewers are
watching those episodes what they don't
realize is that while they're watching
their shows actually they are being
watched
they are being watched by Roy Price and
his team who record everything they
record when somebody presses play when
somebody presses pause what parts they
skip what parts they watch again
so they collect millions of data points
because they want to have those data
points to then decide which show they
should make and sure enough so they
collect all the data they do all the
data crunching and an answer emerges and
the answer is Amazon should do a sitcom
about four Republican US senators they
did that show so does anyone know the
name of the show yes
alpha house um but it seems like not too
many of you who remember that show
actually so because it didn't turn out
that great it's actually just an average
show actually literally in fact because
the average of this curve here is at
seven point four and alpha house lands a
seven point five so slightly above
average show but certainly not what Roy
Price and his team were aiming for
meanwhile however about the same time at
another company another executive did
manage to land a top show using data
analysis and his name is Ted Ted Saran
does who's the chief content officer of
Netflix and just like Roy he's on a
constant mission to find that great TV
show and he uses data as well to do that
except he does it a little bit
differently so instead of holding a
competition what he did and his team of
course was they looked at all the data
they already had about Netflix viewers
you know the ratings they give the shows
the viewing histories what shows people
liked and so on and then they use that
data to discover all of these little
bits and pieces about the audience what
kind of shows they like what kind of
producers what kind of actors and once
they had all these pieces together they
took a leap of faith and they decided to
license not a sitcom about four senators
but a drama series about a single
senator you guys know the show yes
house of cards and Netflix of course
nailed it with that show at least for
the first two seasons house of cards
gets a nine point one rating on this
curve so it's exactly where I wanted it
to be now the question of course is what
happened here so you have two very
competitive data savvy companies they
connect all these millions of data
points and then it works beautifully for
one of them and it doesn't work for the
other one so so why because logic kind
of tells you that this should be working
all the time I mean if you're collecting
millions of data points on a decision
you're going to make then you should be
able to make a pretty good decision you
have 200 years of Statistics to rely on
you're amplifying it with very powerful
computers the least you could expect is
a good TV right and if data analysis
does not work that way then it actually
gets a little scarier because we live in
a time where returning to data more and
more to make very serious decisions that
go far beyond TV does anyone here know
the company Multi health systems no one
okay that's that's good actually okay so
multi health systems is a software
company and I hope that nobody here in
this
ever comes into contact with that
software because if you do it means
you're in prison if someone here in the
US is in prison and they apply for
parole then it's very likely that data
analysis software from that company will
be used in determining whether to grant
that parole so it's the same principle
as Amazon and Netflix but now instead of
deciding whether a TV show is going to
be good or bad you're deciding whether a
person is going to be good or bad and as
you know mediocre TV twenty two minutes
that can be pretty you know bad but more
years in prison I guess even worse and
unfortunately there's actually some
evidence that this data analysis despite
having a lots of data does not always
produce optimum results and that's not
because a company like multi health
systems doesn't know what to do with
data even the most data savvy companies
get it wrong yes even Google gets it
wrong sometimes in 2009 Google announced
that they were able with data analysis
to predict outbreaks of influenza the
nasty kind of flu by doing data analysis
on their on their Google searches and it
worked beautifully and it make a big
splash in the news including the
pinnacle of scientific success of
publication in the journal Nature and
worked beautifully for year after year
after year until one year it failed and
nobody could even tell exactly why it
just didn't work that year and of course
that again made big news including now a
retraction of a publication from the
journal Nature so even the most data
savvy companies Amazon and Google they
sometimes get it wrong and despite all
those failures data is moving rapidly
into real-life decision making into the
workplace
law enforcement medicine so we should
better make sure that data is helping
now personally I've seen a lot of this
struggle with data myself because I work
in computational genetics which is also
a field where lots of very smart people
are using unimaginable amounts of data
to make pretty serious decisions like
deciding on a cancer therapy or
developing a drug
and over the years I've noticed a sort
of pattern or kind of rule if you will
about the difference between successful
decision-making with data and
unsuccessful decision-making and I find
this a pattern worth sharing and it goes
something like this so whenever you're
solving a complex problem you're doing
essentially two things the first one is
you take that problem apart into its
bits and pieces so that you can deeply
analyze those bits and pieces and then
of course you do the second part you put
all of these bits and pieces back
together again to come to your
conclusion and sometimes you have to do
it over again but it's always those two
things you know taking apart and putting
back together again and now the crucial
thing is that data and data analysis is
only good for the first part data and
data analysis no matter how powerful can
only help you taking a problem apart and
understanding its pieces it's not suited
to put those pieces back together again
and then to come to a conclusion there's
another tool that can do that and we all
have it and that tool is the brain if
there's one thing a brain is good at its
taking bits and pieces back together
again even when you have incomplete
information and coming to a good
conclusion especially if it's the brain
of an expert and that's why I believe
that Netflix was so successful because
they use data and brains where they
belong in the process they use data to
first understand lots of pieces about
their audience that they otherwise
wouldn't have been able to understand at
that depth but then the decision to take
all these bits and pieces and put them
back together again and make a show like
house of cards that was nowhere in the
data
tetsu Randall's and his team made that
decision to license that show which also
meant by the way that they were taking a
pretty big personal risk with that
decision
an Amazon on the other hand they did it
the wrong way around they used data all
the way to drive their decision making
first when they held their competition
of TV ideas then when they selected
alpha house to make as a show which of
course was a very safe decision for them
because they could always point at the
data and saying you know this is what
the data tells us but it didn't lead to
the exceptional results that that they
were hoping for so data is of course a
massively useful tool to make better
decisions um but I believe
that things go wrong when data is
starting to drive those decisions no
matter how powerful data is just a tool
and to keep that in mind I find this
device here quite useful many of you
will before there was data
this was the decision-making device to
use as many of you will notice oh this
toy here is called a magic 8-ball and is
really amazing because if you have a
decision to make a yes or no question
all you have to do is you fake the ball
and then you get an answer most likely
right here in this window in real time
I'll have it out later for tech demos
now the thing is of course I mean so
I've made some decisions in my life
where in hindsight I should have just
listened to the ball but you know of
course if you have the data available
you want to replace this with something
much more sophisticated like data
analysis to come to a better decision
but that does not change the basic set
up so the ball may get smarter and
smarter and smarter but I believe it's
still on us to make the decisions if we
want to achieve something extraordinary
on the right end of the curve and I find
that a very encouraging message in fact
that even in the face of huge amounts of
data it still pays off to make decisions
to be an expert in what you're doing and
take risks because in the end it's not
data it's risks that will land you on
the right end of the curve thank you